brad keller gets ready for his second
start against the tigers this season
well this is the one young man that can
control that whether they hit homers or
not by keeping that ball down early
scoring opportunity for the tigers
runners at the corners nobody away for
jonathan scope
quick shot through the legs at third
base of kelvin gutierrez
and robbie grossman scores the tigers
have the one-nothing lead
good start for the tigers some bit as a
gift we'll take it and this ball's hit
hard but you see it just stays down
cutieris thought it was going to come up
didn't right between the wickets tigers
on the board that'll leave it up to
miguel so if you're perez salvador perez
or brad keller you're reading what
miguel's doing what do you see who
blinks first pitch number 10 ground ball
foul miguel will see at least 11 pitches
3-2 ground ball up the middle and into
center field the base hit castro being
waved around third by chip hale and he
will score throw goes to second base
scope gets back safely rbi ground ball
single on the 11th pitch of the at-bat
and the tigers take a two-nothing lead
on the miguel cabrera single what a good
at bat mixture of fastball slider the
entire ad bad and then the hard ground
ball this is a pretty fast infield
that's dangerous territory up the middle
if they're right there he just finds the
perfect spot tigers get another miguel's
got an rbi and a hit base has loaded one
out nikko goodrum in search of a big hit
the 1-1 swinging a shattered bat base
hit into center field
that's going to score two scope is in
right behind him miguel cabrera mazzara
over to third and absolute shattered bat
soft line drive single into center off
the bat of nico goodroom and the tigers
take a four nothing lead here in the
first the barrel of the bat went flying
into the netting above the royals dugout
on the first base side what a big hit
for nico goodrum
boy did he need that rare big first
inning for the tigers and a four nothing
lead first and third one out keel
hitting 246.
left-handed battered ground ball second
maybe two second one first base and
got him both
we kept talking about a double play and
we finally get one
but
not before four score tigers bringing
matt boyd to the mound today this is 12
stars so far this is his 13th start
started off strong had a little struggle
but you know he's got four pitches the
o2 swing the ground ball back to matthew
boyd flips down to second one castro's
relay to first don't have to rush it one
four three inning ending double play
good start for matthew boyd after one in
kansas city in the first of three the
tigers have a four nothing lead one out
nobody on tigers lead by four early in
this one just the third inning three
shifted to the left the 1-1 swinging the
ground ball
by miguel cabrera into right field that
gets merrifield over to third miguel was
coming off the baseball got by him and
the royals have runners at the corners
ground ball single
after the line drive single and with
merrifield that brings up salvador perez
uh-oh
aj hinch is now on his way out to the
mound doug teeter had trainer going with
him they saw something with maddie a
terrific first trip to the order for
boyd something's going on
and that's going to be the end of the
night for boyd wow
that's really
really tough for the tigers tough for
boyd joey minion is is coming on perez
is hit 250 against tiger's pitching this
year
and he went too far that time he did
offer and struck him out for the second
out of the inning now that ball looks
way outside you somebody said how can
you swing at that when you see a guy
swinging a ball like that that tells you
he's not picking it up the 1-0
swinging in a pop-up right to shortstop
nico goodram will step out of the
outfield grass makes the catch great job
by joey menace to strand runners at the
corners castro walked his first time up
on a 3-1 pitch between the fly ball deep
to right field way back and right and
gone
willy castro
left no doubt
the instant that ball left his back
carried the visiting bullpen and ride a
two-run shot is his fifth of the year
and the tigers open up a six-nothing
lead here in the fourth inning beautiful
sight jumping off his bat and you're
reminded of the power
he is not a big guy but when he gets a
hold of one
it goes
six nothing tigers here in the fourth
inning now alberto
blind
fair
and down into the corner
olivares will round third and he will
score
and that gives the fans something to
cheer about
royals have a little two-out rally and
get on the board it's 6-1 tigers leading
there you go
no breaking ball he did the same thing
in his first at-bat and just went foul
off of matthew boyd but this one stayed
slider reaches out
and he's able to pound it 10th double
down the line there you go that's a big
hit there to get him in infield second
and third one out 6-1 tigers the 1-2
pitch golf's one to right
dozier's there cabrera's tagging
and he will score
haas moves up to third tigers now lead
it 7-1 runner at third for the royals
infield will swing around to the left
now for right-handed hitting salvador
perez
salvi hits one to center field and that
will drop
so it's 7-2
salvi drives in his 43rd nicely done
santana made a productive out moved wood
over to third and wit and savvy not
trying to pull use the middle of the
field and that's a good swing let's get
the job done oh boy now
doug teder is being asked to come hailed
out to the mound again motion to the
mound chris feder
something's wrong with alex lang
wow and he's coming out really tough
time for the tigers kyle funkhouser for
the second time tonight a tiger pitcher
has been summoned from the bullpen perez
runner at third solaire at second dozier
at first this will be the sixth pitch of
the at-bat funkhouser ready the 2-2 and
swinging the ground ball
scooped up by castro to the glove side
flips to miguel cabrera funkhouser works
out of the jam the royals have him
loaded again they had him loaded in the
fifth inning jose cisnero will face
jorge solaire who is single and double
tonight and he takes ball four here
comes witt around third but he's gonna
slam on the brakes it didn't roll
far enough away but taylor comes home on
the bases loaded walk
and
there were a couple of strikes in that
sequence hud that solaire did not swing
out he's looked pretty good at the plate
tonight yeah he has you know and
that's a great take right there you
don't you know he doesn't give anything
to him and the royals just seem to be
getting a little bit closer and closer
but they're still
not been a big hit yet he sets holds the
glove high the 1-2 and swinging a high
pop-up
into shallow right willie castro calling
for it and he will make the catch
for out number three
cess walks the first man he faces
strands three
royals have left seven on base the last
three innings
seven three our score here were in the
eighth inning goodram made a splash in
the first a two run single
a drive to left center field
taylor tracking it looks and it's gone
a solo homer for nico goodrum for an
add-on run here in the eighth
and the tigers lead at 8-3 to the top of
the order for robbie grossman the 1-1
that's pounded to deep right field see
ya another solo shot for the tigers this
one courtesy of robbie grossman make it
9-3 detroit that's big there big run now
97 hits away from 3 000 for miguel
cabrera
right side
and under the glove of whitmer field
scope will score there's the 10 spot
10-3 tigers on the rbi single from
miguel cabrera the tigers make a little
history by using daniel norris here in
the ninth it's the first time where the
tigers have used nine pitchers in a nine
inning game
swung on and missed and that's the way
it ends daniel norris comes on does a
nice job and a gratifying victory for
the tigers without question